foreign
so I've got a new segment it's called oh
man I made people mad on the internets
again
does that sound good
I think that sounds great and we should
have plenty of uh of things to talk I'm
finding out that's one of my spiritual
gifts that's one of my love language
it's the sixth secret love language
making people mad on the internet here's
what I posted guys I'm
so much drama
so much drama here's what I wrote
one time my wife and I went to see a
romantic comedy movie
the movie was tragic funny and Charming
about as good as the genre can be
um what it was the movie just like no
secrets it was the
um
they go to the jazz clubs
oh uh La La Land La La Land I loved it I
loved it not me I thought it was great
um
and as we walked out of La La Land like
they're dancing the whole movie and this
great jazz and they're just having all
these moments in the jazz clubs and it's
all Smoky and dark and they're dancing
and falling in love and then it ends and
the only way it could end spoiler alert
terribly it's so good it's so good
back to my post back at the car I had a
thought
I just paid two Hollywood actors to
pretend to be in love to go dancing
together to hang out in jazz clubs and
pretend to live happily ever after
why hadn't I just taken my wife dancing
I paid someone else to do it for me
may I never Outsource my marriage to
strangers and screens again
some of you were super mean on the
internet
going to the movies is fine you're such
a loser to Looney oh my gosh you're
always lecturing us about it
number one
I'm not a big fan of Xanax but y'all
should take a bunch number two
I know the movies are fine I like
watching movies I'm a huge movie nerd I
love it
and
I have found myself and the culture with
without with which I live in
we are the outsourced generation we
Outsource everything
we Outsource our relationships we
Outsource our work we Outsource our
chores at home we Outsource work on our
cars we Outsource our food delivery we
Outsource everything
and it occurred to me
huh
I probably talked about it on the show
and this is I'm just thinking about it's
just just now
so Kelly you may have to edit this out
this idea of of soul mates
star-crossed lovers right and I think
I've mentioned on the show that whole
idea of soul mates comes from
two 13 year olds who wanted to hook up
and they ended up
secretly getting married and then died
in a murder-suicide plot Romeo and
Juliet that's how we that's the standard
we hold up to the most romantic story
ever told it's not it was two idiotic
Teenagers Who Died
it's not romance at all not even close
to romance it's two idiotic teenagers
who didn't have
Tick Tock it probably would have saved
everybody a bunch of trouble
and then I think of my grandparents who
were married 70 something years
and they got married super young and
then my granddad went to World War II
and they came back and they raised four
kids the idea of a soul mate what what
in the world
nonsense and then
after 50 years
60 years 70 years of marriage
they're both just sitting in chairs
going what huh
huh
then my granddad passed away
and my grandmother
made several comments to how like her
body didn't work
because a part of her body had left
and so I realized over 70 years they
became soul mates because they lived in
the trenches together and they did life
together and they did
the Vietnam War together worried about
their boys getting taken off to war they
did recessions together they did we
don't have enough money for food they
did kids getting in trouble they did
grandkids passing away they did all that
together and over time because they
didn't Outsource their relationships
they were going to have joy they weren't
going to pay somebody else to do it
because they didn't have that kind of
money they had to go dancing
they had to go for a walk and hold hands
they had to figure it out
and I walked out of that movie and
thought I I a few places in the world
make me happier than a jazz club I love
them I love The Pianist I love the music
I love the Mad Jazz and I'm like what
are y'all doing and my brain starts to
have a minor
epileptic episode like I love it
I like the blue lights I like the whole
thing
I just paid
forty dollars or whatever it cost to go
to the movies now
for somebody else to do that for me and
me and my wife just sat there eating
popcorn and Twizzlers and then we just
went home
I'm kind of done with that
kind of done with it
at the end of my life I want there not
to be much tread left on the tires and I
don't want to butt cheek imprints in my
couch
I want to have lived my life not paid
somebody else to live it for me
and that comes to my parenting that
comes to romance that comes to
Adventures that comes to all of it
and I remember when we lived downtown
Nashville we had no backyard Hank and I
would go on something we called
Adventure walks he was really young
whatever uh eight or nine and we would
collect odd weird things in alleys
it was wild little nuts and bolts and
sticks and metal pieces and
stuff I'd be like yeah everybody want to
touch that let's don't touch that or I'd
cover it up with leaves because I was
like whoa
but we went searching for adventure and
we often found it or we'd spend an hour
chasing one lizard around it like we
just went and found Adventure here's my
point stop Outsourcing your life
guys take her dancing I Don't Dance I'm
shut up and take her dancing
wives go to that dumb concert just go
just go
even if you're like it's too loud get
ear plugs just go listen to the music on
the way to on the way to work when
you're by yourself
I've been practicing listening to
country music so my son will love me a
little bit more and now I kinda
like that's a secret if you tell anybody
I'm gonna call you a liar
at the end of the day
stop Outsourcing your life whatever that
looks like for you go get your own
groceries if you can do your laundry
don't just call Jeff Bezos for
everything actually make a list and go
to Home Depot and shake hands with one
of those old guys they're awesome
stop Outsourcing your life build your
own treehouse
stop Outsourcing your life